welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor David skelly a
professor of ecology at Yale's
environment school professor skelly is
interested in animal ecology
conservation and management his studies
of amphibians are directed at
determining the causes of patterns such
as evolution and the extinction and
establishment of populations today we're
going to talk to Professor skelly about
rapid evolution the idea that evolution
can keep pace with environmental change
welcome professor Skelly thank you much
of your research is focused on
amphibians how did you become interested
in them well I went to graduate school
thinking that I was going to study fish
I had been interested in fish for much
of my childhood and when I got to the
University of Michigan where I went to
graduate school my advisor had switched
to amphibians and so I started my first
study with amphibians and have learned
that they're very useful group to study
your latest research looks at species
when they invade a new environment tell
me about your research in Australia with
the cane toads well this work is a
collaboration with some colleagues at
the University of Sydney who have been
watching the cane toads move across the
Australian continent they were
introduced intentionally to try to
control pests in 1935 and they kind of
failed in that assignment and then they
overstayed their welcome and they've
been spreading across the continent and
they're there a problem because they're
they're toxic and in being toxic they
get picked up by native predators by
people's dogs in their backyards and
those animals that try to eat them off
and die so Australians care a great deal
about cane toads there's a very amusing
documentary movie that's been made about
their spread but seriously they're a big
problem so one of the big questions is
how far are they going to get and how
asked we we tackled that problem and
came up with a kind of a surprising
answer and that is that they were going
to go a lot farther than people had
originally suspected and that that
garnered a great deal of attention in
Australia and elsewhere where people
think about invasive species the reason
that was interesting is because it looks
like the reason they're moving so far so
fast is because since nineteen
thirty-five they've evolved and that's
really surprising okay so what does this
mean for the management of the species
when it's introduced well that's a good
question what it means essentially is
that managers and policymakers that are
trying to monitor and make decisions
about how animals move across
international borders across oceans need
to consider whether that animal is going
to be the same in the new country as it
was in its home country and the emerging
answer is that we can't count on that so
the tried and true method of doing some
field trials and saying well this thing
lives on this in this kind of an area
and it eats this kind of a thing we may
not be able to depend on that and so
that means that there should be greater
caution when we're trying to use animals
for good as was the case with a cane
toad trying to control a pest it wasn't
able to do that very well and then it's
turned into something else that's living
in environments that no one would have
ever predicted based on where it lived
in in Central and South America Wow so
it could be quite the problem yes okay
the second element of your research
deals with the study of evolution in
response to changing temperature right
what are you working on now well so our
other rapid evolution project is looking
at a North American species and this is
one of the first times in my research
career that I've worked on what happens
to local populations with ramifications
for thinking about a global phenomenon
most of the time ecologists if asked
what's going to matter for my population
would start giving you answers that are
based on local factors well there's it's
it's sunnier here or at shady or here
wetter
I or whatever and usually that's that's
based on local habitat differences but
now for the first time with climate
change ecologists are forced to deal
with the idea that what may matter most
for their population or certainly may
matter a lot is something that's
happening on a much bigger scale than
their populations exist on so in this
case we're working with North American
species that live in a whole variety of
environments they live in deeply shaded
ponds these are amphibians that breed in
the water and then emerge onto the land
but they have to go through this life
history stage in these ponds and the the
ponds can be either cool and shady or
warm and sunny and so we're using this
as a surrogate for understanding how
these same types of animals and other
animals may evolve in response to
climate change so we've got cool
conditions and warm conditions that can
change very fast just as the trees grow
up or they get cut down or hurricane
knocks them down that all happens on the
scale of decades the same kind of scale
that we think climate change is going to
happen on these species it turns out
respond evolutionarily to these changing
temperature conditions just as the
environment changes at the same pace as
far as we can tell so that the animals
that live in these cool shady conditions
are actually able to do a few tricks
they choose the tadpoles choose where
they're going to live based on
temperature so they actually seek out
little Sun flecks in the pond to raise
their body temperature which helps them
grow and develop faster they have a
higher critical thermal maximum that
means that they can survive warmer
temperatures if they live in warmer
environments and cooler ones if they
live in cooler environments and they
also will develop faster in colder
environments if that's where they live
and these differences exist on on a
stone's throw sort of a distance scale
so a shady pond right next to a sunny
pond will have frog populations that
have evolved those local conditions this
is really surprising to evolutionary
biologists and it's dumbfounding to
conservation biologists even though
conservation biology has biology in its
name and even though the cornerstone of
biology is evolutionary by
LG most conservation scientists don't
think about evolution at all they've if
they've learned anything at all about it
they've learned that it's too slow to
matter and what we're discovering with
this study the cane toad study and
others is that it's typical probably in
nature for evolution to be just as fast
as environmental change that doesn't
mean these are big huge changes it's not
one species turning into another but
they're big enough to matter they're
going to change how these actors in the
environment behave and they're going to
change how they interact with others
it's going to change the ecology so it
does matter so why is it important to
understand how global climate change can
affect species well the temperature
changes that we're looking at on the
order of 3 or 4 degrees Celsius are the
same changes that are expected to happen
over the same half century or so and and
the the temporal scale of the the trees
falling back or growing up is about the
same as well so we're looking at a
phenomenon that's happening at the same
scales that global climate change is
presumed to happen and temperatures
temperatures so if they can evolve
rapidly in response to the kinds of
temperature changes we're looking at
we're fairly confident that they're
going to evolve in response to these
other changes now there's two ways to
view this relative to climate change on
the one hand people who want to argue
that it doesn't matter can say well so
species are going to be able to evolve
there was a study that came out a few
years ago that said up to a third of all
species are going to go extinct because
of climate change well our group would
argue that that number may be a bit high
and that a great many more species
instead of going extinct are going to
undergo natural selection anything that
can threaten a species with extinction
is altering survivorship and growth and
fecundity of that species enough to also
pose a selection event and so many more
species are going to change now some of
these changes can be viewed as an impact
of climate change as well so some
fraction of species are going to go
extinct some greater fraction are going
to be different because of climate
change and some of those differences are
of concern all by them
selection often tends to narrow genetic
diversity and as we narrow this kind of
biological diversity the ability of
these species to deal with future
challenges may be compromised the other
thing is that we want to conserve
biological diversity in general and we
you know conservation biology is this
kind of melange of societal values and
hard-nosed science and our job is
scientist is to provide the scientific
information but the people who get
emotional about this stuff and there are
many of them want things to be as they
were now whether that's realistic or not
that's what they're concerned about and
what we're showing is that even species
that don't go extinct are going to be
fundamentally changed because of climate
change many of them you have said that
the reason we get sick is because the
environmental context has changed and
that the way we change the environment
may come back to change us can you
elaborate on that sure some of our
research is in the ecology of disease
disease ecology is somewhat different
than medicine in that in medicine it's
been traditional to focus on the patient
and to learn what the symptoms are and
then treat those symptoms disease
ecology is a perspective that's focused
on why plants and animals including
humans but but in this case nonhumans
why they get sick and you often the the
kinds of things that make animals sick
are around in the environment all the
time and so there there are pathogens
out there that are just there all the
time but what what happens to make an
individual sick is that the environment
challenge challenges you somehow and may
weaken your ability to resist disease
many people will have anecdotes where
they feel like they got knocked down by
something and and while they weren't
feeling well because of that they got
infected those anecdotes are probably
based on real real things that happen to
people in many cases and the concern
with global climate change
that we're going to be putting perhaps
more people are certainly different
groups of people in situations where
they're going to be challenged by the
environment and in so doing we're going
to subject some populations to greater
likelihood of disease and those diseases
are selection events and humans are
still evolving to deal with those so
that's where that quotation comes from
do you think we should be concerned
about rapid evolution I think we should
be focused on rapid evolution in the
sense that it's something that's real
and it matters and the way that I can
bring that home to people is you think
about the flu vaccine that you got this
year when we think about medical
intervention people don't think twice
about how evolution figures into the way
we live our lives but there's a group of
people out there every year that try to
forecast the evolution of the flu virus
they look at what flu was around where
last year which ones are growing which
ones are shrinking and that's how they
make up the cocktail that we get
injected into our arms every year so in
certain contexts it's not controversial
and it's totally under people's radar
screens but when we try more more
broadly to say evolution matters and we
need to deal with it I think what we
need to do with the public is be more
specific how do we deal with this once
we establish that rapid evolution is
something that we can expect how do we
use that knowledge in a sense to try to
have evolution work for us or at least
not against us a great example is the
way we harvest fishery stocks both in
freshwater and marine environments for
most of the history of managed fisheries
we've taken the biggest individuals and
over time what we're causing is fish to
mature it's smaller and smaller sizes
and so the average fish that hits your
dinner plate is getting smaller and
smaller and that has its own
ramifications for the species survival
in the wild it also influences the
economics of the whole thing as well so
it really matters in that sense and
finally
this is being recognized and we're now
managing fisheries stocks in more
sophisticated ways that may allow fish
to become bigger and to preserve brute
stocks that will will keep fish larger
and potentially health or healthier
better able to resist predators and so
on that's a great example that can be
extended to the way that we move species
around when we're going to reintroduce
species in the wild we should be
thinking about the genetic stock that
they came from and and maybe even
forecast the way the environment is
going to change before we move something
into the environment there are many
examples like this where rapid evolution
can just help us do a better job thanks
very much for being here today with us
and sharing some of your research thank
you for more information about professor
skelly and his fascinating research
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash mcmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
McMillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies
you